ja die geschichte dieser corona krise
die nämlich so geht alles was in
österreich eingeführt wird kommt dann
zwei wochen später zu uns jetzt eben hat
der neue kanzler alexander schallenberg
gesagt dass die impfpflicht kommt wie
soll da im frühjahr april eingeführt
werden in österreich und zack zumindest
läuft schon genau diese debatte jetzt
heißt ab dem wochenende hier in
deutschland und ganz genauso der lok da
und gerade wieder eingeführt war den
aussies heute in kraft getreten und eben
jetzt auch mittlerweile die ersten
locker und zumindest regional wieder in
deutschland also der blick nach
österreich der lohn und auch das noch
mal schauen wir ganz genau was der
musiker alexander schallenberg dazu
gesagt hat zum neuen lok da und dort
ab montag für maximal 20 tage wird ein
bundesweiter lockdown gelten denn nach
zehn tagen evaluiert wird er endet
automatisch spätestens am 13 dezember ab
diesem datum ab dem 13 dezember gilt für
geimpfte und genesene kein lockt um mehr
wir berichten aus unserem nachbarland
aus unserem lieblings urlaubsland mit
klara marie becker aus salzburg und
unserem reporter jörg völkerling aus ist
schön guten morgen klara marie becker in
salzburg lockdown nummer 4 herrmann
trotzdem kam zu fragen aber wir nehmen
die menschen das jetzt hin
entschuldige praktiziere ich habe gerade
deine frage nicht ganz verstanden
vielleicht könntest du dir eine wahl
wieder locker und nummer vier jetzt dort
ankommt
ja also wir stehen hier in der
salzburger altstadt gestern abend um 11
uhr haben hier alle geschäfte cafés bars
restaurants zugemacht gestern abend
waren tatsächlich noch einiger menschen
in der stadt unterwegs waren nochmal ein
letztes mal im restaurant haben noch ein
letztes bier in der kneipe getrunken
bevor seine lockdown geht und wir stehen
hier in der getreidegasse in der
altstadt das normalerweise eine sehr
beliebte einkaufsstraße ist auch ein
beliebter touristen hotspot und dies
wirklich wie leergefegt also hier sieht
man nur menschen die auf dem weg zur
arbeit sind und hier schnell durch
wischen und ansonsten ist salzburg wie
ausgestorben
weiter nach hinspiel zu unserem kollegen
jörg völkerling bei dem es kurz ein
bisschen dunkel geworden ist was ich
erklär uns gleich einmal wo du bist
dabei ist natürlich für uns sozusagen
die als corona hölle in unserem
gedächtnis geblieben wie ist die lage
dort wenn man jetzt wieder in den lock
down geht und dass wieder in der
skisaison
relax if you can das wäre der
werbespruch von
können und relaxen kann im moment
niemand in ischgl auch hier ist wieder
der lockdown hereingebrochen wir sitzen
jetzt gerade in der silvretta seilbahn
auf dem weg zur 2800 meter hohen flimm
spitze die bergbahn ist eigentlich
bereit touristen zu empfangen ab
donnerstag sollte hier eröffnet werden
alle mitarbeiter sind am start wir
sitzen jetzt hier in der seilbahn bei
uns ist günter zange der vorstand der
silvretta seilbahn ag wie wir etwas für
gefühle ist das sozusagen über einen
perfekten kabarettist beat zu fliegen
hier und trotzdem ist sind keine gäste
da die transportieren könnte ja die
situation ist natürlich frustrierend vor
allem weil wir ja bis vor wenigen tagen
davon ausgegangen sind dass wir
aufsperren können
es hat sich leider in den letzten tagen
aber auch die infektions lage in
österreich sehr sehr verschafft und
deswegen hat unsere regierung am freitag
wieder einen bundesweiten lockt am
beschlossen
jetzt ist ja gestern die verwirrung
komplett geworden gestern kurzfristig
kam eine neuregelung da heißt es jetzt
dürfen die seilbahn doch oder bei der
die skigebiete dürfen trotzdem öffnen
wie geht ihr damit um macht er jetzt auf
also spricht nur für für leute die
einheimisch sind dass die auf die pisten
können die hotels haben ja sowieso
geschlossen für touristischen betrieb
wie nehmt ihr diese botschaft jetzt auf
könnte jetzt trotzdem auf stand ja das
problem ist immer dass irgendetwas
verkündet wird bei einer pressekonferenz
letztlich klar ist was gibt aber immer
erst wenn die entsprechende verordnung
auch vor liegt diese vor allem wurde
offenbar im entwurfsstadium noch einmal
geändert das heißt es hat dann plötzlich
geheißen es wird möglich sein seilbahnen
zu betreiben diese information kam sehr
überraschend und auch kurz frei die für
uns das heißt wir wissen dass eigentlich
erst seit gestern 19 uhr müssen uns
diese rechtlichen vorgaben jetzt genau
anschauen und werden dann entscheiden
wie wir weiter vorgehen was ist denn
eigentlich der größere schock für euch
diese wucht mit der sozusagen diese
berichterstattung über ins spiel
hereingebrochen ist der ground zero der
europäischen corona krise oder die angst
davor jetzt in die zweite ausgefallene
skisaison zu gehen also vielleicht
eventuell wieder ein komplettausfall
dieser wintersaison zu haben ja wir
bleiben trotz allem optimistisch dass
wir am 13 da ist er das ende des
lockouts angekündigt am 13 dann
tatsächlich starten können und zwar mit
beherbergung mit gastronomie und auch
mit skibetrieb die situation ist glaube
ich trotz allem doch besser als sie im
letzten jahr war wir haben heuer eine
impfung wir haben leider wie gesagt
wieder sehr hohe infektionszahlen wir
gehen aber davon aus dass die jetzt
verkündeten sehr strengen maßnahmen dann
doch ihre wirkung zeigen werden jan
gesehen unten an der talstation teure
mitarbeiter sind quasi vollzählig am
start mit hoch hatte die höchstzahl
sozusagen erreicht die pisten sind
präpariert die bahn fährt ja heute auch
deswegen die fährt nicht für uns sondern
fährt damit eure mitarbeiter auch hoch
kommen können auch an die bergstation
auf die treppe wie ist das bei euch wie
handhabt ihr das mit impfungen sind eure
mitarbeiter alle geimpft habt ihr das
verlangt ist das verpflichtend wie ist
das bei euch also in österreich 3g am
arbeitsplatz das heißt geimpft genießen
oder getestet wir haben natürlich sehr
sehr viele mitarbeiter die mittlerweile
geimpft sind
verpflichtend vorgeschrieben ist es in
österreich nicht und das können wir auch
als betrieb nicht machen das heißt es
gibt natürlich auch mitarbeiter die sich
das hat heute begonnen
tagtäglich oder jeden zweiten tag
aktuell testen lassen müssen er hatte
aber schon um sich vorzubereiten auf
diese kommende wintersaison diverse
sicherheitsmaßnahmen auch für die gäste
getroffen kann können sie das mal ein
bisschen einfach umschreiben was hier
einfach anstatt gebracht wurde ja es gab
ja bereits für den letzten winter ein
sehr umfassendes hygiene und sicherheit
wir haben hier insgesamt rund 700.000
euro investiert in diese maßnahmen die
reichen von desinfektionen von kabinen
über
entsprechende informationen
beschilderungen über entsprechende
abgrenzungen oder abtrennungen die wir
in den restaurants gemacht haben es gibt
beispielsweise auch bei den zubringer
bahnen ein intelligentes kamerasystem
das uns hilft das abstände eingehalten
werden das menschenmassen besser gelenkt
werden können und zwar indem in echtzeit
quasi die wartezeiten bei diesen bahnen
angezeigt werden das heißt das sind
alles dinge die hätten wir im letzten
jahr auch schon vorbereitet gehabt
konnten sie da allerdings nicht
ausprobieren und haben das ganze für
heuer natürlich entsprechend adaptiert
also wir sehen hier in
wörterberg gebiete beispiel ist man
eigentlich vorbereitet auf eine perfekte
wintersaison wir sehen die bilder hier
seit ende oktober laufen auch die 1100
beschneiungsanlagen und etwas neidisch
und traurig blickt man wahrscheinlich 80
km weiter nach deutschland nach garmisch
wo seit letzter woche auch den berg
hinunter gebetet werden kann und man hat
nun der dinge ob mitte dezember dieses
bild auch hier in österreich in einem
der größten skigebiete verwirklicht
werden kann man mit diesen eindrücken
aus ischgl gebe ich jetzt erst mal
zurück zu euch nach berlin vielen dank
jörg völkerling ist können wir schon
noch mal nach salzburg zu klarer marie
becker er immer mehr menschen gehen
österreicher auch auf die straße was ist
davon zu spüren klara marie wäre hier
gehen die menschen jetzt dort auf diese
erneute nachricht gibt es da noch viel
verständnis denn besonders jetzt in der
wintersaison und auch in der
vorweihnachtlichen zeit wo viele läden
und geschäfte ja auf die ganzen
einnahmen angewiesen sind
ja verständnis gibt es hier nicht mehr
viel das merkt man auf jeden fall wenn
man mit den menschen spricht wie haben
heute morgen mit einem ladenbesitzer aus
der getreidegasse gesprochen der gesagt
hat wir verstehen es nicht mehr wir
haben keine lust mehr wir versuchen uns
nur vor dem aussterben zu retten wir
wissen nicht mehr wie sie über die
runden kommen sollen und verständnis hat
man da auf jeden fall nicht raus in
salzburg ist es bislang ruhig geblieben
wir haben ja am wochenende mitbekommen
dass es proteste in wien zum beispiel
gab in salzburg war davon jetzt noch
nichts zu spüren aber die leute sind mit
ihrer geduld auf jeden fall am ende und
sie man merkt einfach dass sie darauf
hoffen dass es mit einem schnellen
harten lockdown der ja nach zehn tagen
neu bewertet werden soll dann auch
erledigt ist aktuell liegt die sieben
tage incidents hier in salzburg aber bei
1.750 also wirklich sehr hoch und 34 von
insgesamt 180 intensivbetten hier in
salzburg sind schon mit corona patienten
belegt das heißt das land salzburg hat
ja schon am donnerstag vor der
österreichischen regierung beschlossen
hier ab montag in den lock down zu gehen
aus der angst heraus dass eben eine
überlastung der intensivstation in den
nächsten tagen und wochen möglich sein
könnte und die hoffnung die die
österreichische regierung ihren bürgern
macht nach zehn tagen könnte dann alles
vorbei sein mit dem lockdown aller
allerspätestens nach 20 tagen das ist
möglicherweise dann das nächste
versprechen was kassiert werden muss